another item that democrats are trying
to get done here
falls on the shore the shoulders the
mighty shoulders
of elizabeth warren another
new york times article elizabeth warren
will propose a minimum tax on the
nation's richest companies
now this comes on the heels of reporting
from from several years ago
where there were over 90 companies of
the
largest corporations in america that
paid zero
income tax zero
john deere zero amazon
zero this falls this comes on the heels
of the reporting from just a few months
ago from propublica
of all of the billionaires who didn't
pay
any tax elon musk
jeff bezos warren buffett perennial
liberal advocate for for raising taxes
on the wealthy
he didn't pay very much
reading from this article senator
elizabeth warren of massachusetts and
her allies will propose a minimum
tax on the profits of the nation's
richest companies regardless
of what they say they owe the government
as part of the democrats 3.5 trillion
dollar economic and social policy
package
miss warren's so-called real corporate
profits tax was a key
part of her presidential campaign and
she has enlisted senator angus king
the main independent to help press her
case
that profitable companies should be
taxed regardless of loopholes
and maneuvers that have allowed many of
them to avoid federal corporate income
taxes altogether
what does it say about our system the
morality of our system
that we demonize those who are getting
ready to be evicted from their houses
we demonize the unhoused
and we lift up as paragons as examples
of how to live
billionaires who who enjoy
outrageous wealth unimaginable wealth
who pay nothing into the system
instead they live off loans using
stock as collateral and then that loan
ends up being a liability that they
actually can get a
tax break from it is
immoral
i'm not necessarily opposed
to billionaires i am opposed to a system
that allows them to to exist with
impunity
continuing on here the measure would
require the most profitable companies to
pay a seven percent tax on the earnings
they report to investors
known as their annual book value above
100 million
by taxing the earnings reported to
investors not to the internal revenue
service
democrats would be hitting earnings that
companies like to maximize
not the earnings they try hard to
diminish for tax purposes
and this is what elizabeth warren had to
say
about this during the presidential
campaign joe biden and i disagreed on
some tax policies
but there was one thing we strongly
agreed on
corporations shouldn't be able to tell
shareholders
they were making huge profits then tell
the irs they made nothing
in profits
truer words when jeff bezos and his
cadre of billionaire pals
benefit from a system that we have that
has
made them what they are of course there
was hard work that
went into it i'm not saying that doesn't
play a role
but luck plays and plays an outsized
role
in the success of people like this it's
not just their ingenuity
there are a million points of data
that lead to their success
what's what's the phrase about uh
preparation and luck
when when combined some nonsense saying
fortune favors the well-prepared or
whatever
all of that is true but without luck
and without the sweat and the and the
the tears and the blood and the
sacrifice
of people who work for these
corporations they would
have nothing and to
to enjoy the spoils of everything that
is benefiting them that this country
offers
and then to pay zero in tax whether you
be a corporation
or whether you be an individual like
jeff bezos or elon musk
it is immoral it is reprehensible and it
needs to be
legislated we need
people on capitol hill elected
representatives
that is after all what they do they
represent us
and they need to do more for us
and not the people who who make uh major
payments to their packs
major contributions to their political
campaigns
that is what's most important we the
people
not we the corporation i've struggled
falling asleep at night and realized
part of it could be because of the blue
light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that
blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin
which can make it difficult to fall
asleep blue light can disturb
your circadian rhythms but it hasn't
been an issue for me
since i discovered blue blocks glasses
which filter out that blue light they're
one of our sponsors
a lot of other companies are mass
producing supposed blue light glasses
and factories with no actual quality
standards
blue blocks glasses are made in actual
optics labs at their headquarters in
australia
they have over 40 stylish frames a
prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks
sells they give a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video
and there's free shipping worldwide
on orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars